we used to think that the brain
controlled all our movements so when you
had a spinal cord injury if you lost
that communication between the brain and
the spinal cord it's really nothing you
can do unless you regenerate that
connection it turns out the spinal cord
has much more of a sophisticated role
than we thought before we can stimulate
the neural networks in the spinal cord
we can help the spinal cord relearn how
to do things it was able to do before
injury I was supposed to been an
individual that was gonna live and die
from this chair I mean with the epidural
stimulator it's so close to the point of
just move this leg you're growing the
ability to recovery I really think like
it's gonna give me the availability to
get out of his chair growing up we
started out with go-karts and then we
got into bicycles and everything my
grandpa took me to my first Supercross
race seeing that and instilled me with
this want that that's what I wanted to
do my career was at the point where I
was amateur Pro there's a couple races
and then I had my pro points where then
I could race the stuff that you see on
TV I went out I was testing a new
motorcycle that I just got and it was a
like a hundred foot jump right off the
face of that jump my member the motor
just locked up but had me pinned and
then it just couldn't just tumble tumble
tumble and some people can touch me
alright you know you okay and I'm like
no I don't think so
can you get up I was like no you're
paralyzed from the waist down your
complete injury you can't feel anything
you're not gonna regain any mobility any
function from here on out you're gonna
have to have daily care more than likely
you're left from a wheelchair and just
that was a lot to swallow basically how
I took it was that from that point on my
life was starting to end versus it
continuing to be an adventure that was
I felt to me
[Music]
when I got that prognosis the first
thing I went to was looking at sinners
that offered rehab and locomotor
training and what for the top ones that
was where I kind of heard through the
grapevine that they had a guy in
Louisville that was going through the
procedure for the epidural stimulator
and they were seeing some very
interesting things happen
we were doing a series of experiments we
implanted an individual with the
epidural stimulator it was laying down
and he on his own tried to move Ahlan
Terrell tried to move his toes and he
wiggled his toe I said holy we did not
anticipate that we tested it the
stimulator off and they cannot move when
you turn the stimulator on they're able
to this dude's got a you got a switch
that just makes it normal that's how it
was making me perceive it our whole
theory about how the motor system works
was challenged
[Music]
so the traditional way of thinking about
a spinal cord injury is that the brain
is the primary controller of movement
and function but it turns out the spinal
circuitry is as smart as the brain it
can learn it can remember it can forget
and it can make decisions how we
actually walk is this circuitry already
has in it the ability to generate
patterns to walk as devastating as a
spinal cord injury is that circuitry
still has the ability to do that but it
loses what we would call state of
excitability so the epidural stimulator
is an off-the-shelf pain stimulator
that's used in people for pain it has
leads that's placed in the lower spinal
cord and it generates an electric field
so the stimulator actually helps those
neurons that are still viable that are
still alive to be able to function like
they did before
it's five days a week two sessions a day
I started with a toe and then it started
with an ankle and then it started with a
leg twelve sessions in I got my first
Holt of Independence in standing it's
gotten to the point now or it just
happens naturally I just lean forward on
my Walker and think that I want to stand
and I stand in my legs they hold me when
you immediately turn on you don't really
notice but once you get a couple volts
up it's like you feel the body charged
and ready when you're trying you feel
that go through your head from your
brain down your spine to that leg give
them some body weight support keep them
balanced and then people move their legs
in a walking leg pattern that sends the
right information about walking back to
the spinal cord which it's expecting and
because the spinal cord smart and it can
learn it starts relearning how to walk
again with that information and the
person's thinking about walking and over
time in some people they are able to
step independently and in two people
walk completely independently from
physical assistance but just use a
walker or canes
to walk over ground the biggest thing is
filling it because after injury you feel
nothing and when you execute those
movements you feel them there you go I
exploded a vertebra what is known before
all this is there's no way no how that
I'd ever be able to take a step again
but that's wrong the next step really
needs to be to design one that is very
specific for this use so the device that
we envision is akin to a smartphone it
can be voice activated so as okay I want
to stand now so you've your stand
program I want to walk now do you have
your walk program it has closed-loop
feedback so blood pressure is monitored
do all of this as autonomously as
possible
this is not a cure there's not going to
be a silver bullet for this there's not
any where I think in the near horizon
where we're going to completely
regenerate the spinal cord after an
injury but if we can make an incremental
change in function and improves our
participation in life one of the things
that hit you when you're in the hospital
am I ever gonna get married and my mom
kids and at this point I'm married and
therefore no stimulator program gave me
the ability to stand at my wedding soon
as she started walking down the aisle
that motion just hit me like I'm not I
don't really cry but man I was bawling
[Music]
even getting the dancing my mom I mean
that was that was so awesome and I feel
so close to the kids thing like I know
it's I know it's coming
you